big fire-breathing dragons they're just
bees from fairy tales and fantasy
fiction right that's basically true but
those stories only tell a fraction of
the Dragons vast history and I'm here
today to tell you that dragons are real
sort of I'm dr. Emily's Orca and this is
monstrum
[Music]
we like dragons because let's be honest
they look cool
many of us have pets and the dragon is
the ultimate fantasy something beautiful
yet ferocious both loyal and capable of
protecting us
dragons have been a part of human
culture for thousands of years countless
countries and cultures have integrated
stories of large serpentine creatures
into their oral storytelling art and
literature but why early discoveries of
inexplicable natural phenomenon let our
imagination run wild the mystifying
nature of the dragon can most probably
be accounted for by human encounters
with an astounding creature like a large
aquatic animal floating just below the
surface an abnormally large snake even
an aggressive Komodo dragon became
legendary monsters in the 13th century
Marco Polo famously claimed to encounter
huge serpents with two legs and sharp
teeth while traveling in China writing
the jaws are wide enough to swallow a
man the teeth are large and sharp and
their whole appearance is so formidable
that neither man nor any kind of animal
can approach them without terror now it
is generally believed that these dragons
polo spoke of were in fact just
crocodiles dragon myths are in part a
response to these encounters and there
is a rich history to them that spans
across many cultures each dragon is
unique to the time and place of its
creation this is why there is no one
type of dragon not all breathe fire some
don't even have wings or feet this is a
dragon but so is this even these guys
are all considered dragons but what
accounts for such wide differences in
appearance while there are examples of
dragons all across the globe from the
benevolent shape-shifting dragons of
China to the feathered Mesoamerican
dragon God for now let's just focus on
those most common in fantasy literature
the classical dragon and one of my
personal favorites the wyvern the wyvern
is a dragon frequently as
with United Kingdom its distinct from
other types of dragons because it's
reptilian body possesses wings but only
two legs george RR martin adopted the
wyvern style of dragon Khaleesi x'
reptilian children have very long necks
and Tails large wings and only hind legs
martin considered biology alongside myth
when crafting dragon and his siblings
arguing that living or dead from bat to
pterodactyl no beast in nature has four
legs and wings well tell that to the
creators of the classical dragon
recognizable by their four legs and
powerful wings this form of dragon is
the one most commonly seen today so how
do we explain these differences before
paleontology existed skeletal remains
were not always recognizable as the
bones belonging to long dead animals the
prehistoric marine reptiles Plesiosaurus
were large long necked creatures with
for long flippers pleasee asaurus
fossils easily could have been mistaken
for the two wings and two legs of a
wyvern or even the four legs of a
classical dragon even today we find more
evidence that previous cultures
encountered reptilian fossils in 2015 an
ancient fossil was discovered that
appeared serpentine and has four legs
and a recent discovery in China revealed
this two legged dinosaur with a pair of
bat-like wings so um yeah dragons are
real j.r.r tolkien had his own taxonomic
system for dragons he classifies the
creatures by their capacity to breathe
fire and how they move around his
writings to pick dragons with and
without wings with legs and without an
only son capable of breathing fire his
most famous dragon the clever treasure
guarding wicked worm Smaug checks off
multiple boxes in Tolkien's taxonomy
like many authors today Tolkien combines
different dragon myths to create the
most terrifying beast
the most iconic trait of the Dragon is
its ability to breathe fire but where
did this attribute come from the
development of fire-breathing dragons
could have been a result of the
geological features of northern Europe
specifically it the presence of natural
gas events a wayward lightning strike
were dropped torched by a miner could
have provided the spark that set a
tongue of flame or wave of noxious gas
to the surface not having a way to
explain this natural phenomenon we
filled in the gaps with a supernatural
explanation the fire-breathing dragon
this may also partially explain why
Dragons are associated with guarding
treasure often below ground or in dark
caves miners would have been likely
trying to deter thieves with scary
stories of a monstrous creature
protecting their own fortunes depictions
of the dragon as a fire-breathing
creature appear as early as the 10th
century when the gates of Hell were said
to be the flaming mouth of a demonic
Beast so what can we make from thousands
of years of stories and images of
dragons what can these tales teach us
the dragon represents a human
appreciation and respect for the power
of nature they remind us to tread
carefully across rivers to avoid dark
caverns and to humble us in the presence
of be stronger than ourselves the dragon
is legendary it doesn't really matter so
much whether or not it existed what does
matter is that in an age when nature was
mostly unexplained dragons were a way to
make sense of the world that seemed much
more mysterious second one Sassie I told
you I'd like I told you told you dragons
are real
[Music]